>> Greg: TO THE MONOLOGUE.
ACCORDING TO THE HAIR ON FIRE
MEDIA, CHASING AMBULANCES DOWN
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, THERE'S
BEEN A REPORT OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE IN A LARGE WHITE
RESIDENTS.
>> WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT WAS A
POSSIBLE ANALOGY BETWEEN WHAT WE
ARE SEEING IN THE PRESIDENT AND
STUDIES OF VIOLENCE AND ACTING
OUT, PARTICULARLY WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE.
THE QUESTION WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES FROM A BEHAVIORAL
SENSES ARE WE WATCHING THE
PRESIDENT ESSENTIALLY ON HIS WAY
TO WHAT WE CALL FLASH POINT?
ARE WE BEGINNING TO SEE HIM ACT
OUT IN THE FORM OF PURGING AND
MASS FIRING AND COMPLETELY NOT
LISTENING TO ANY LOGIC?
ARE WE ESSENTIALLY WATCHING A
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE INCIDENT PLAY
OUT TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF OUR
GOVERNMENT?
IS HE ACTING OUT NOW?
WHERE DOES THIS GO IF I'M RIGHT?
>> Greg: CAN I SAY HOLY CRAP.
THAT MAY BE THE MOST INSANE
THING EVER SAID ON MSNBC.
THEY EMPLOY CHRIS MATTHEWS.
YOU WONDER WHY AMERICA THINKS
THE MEDIA IS LESS TRUSTWORTHY
THAN LAWN DARTS?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY SERIOUSLY
ENTERTAIN IDEAS LIKE THAT.
FIRING SOMEONE IS NOW WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE IT FEELS LIKE
THAT FOR THE NONSKILLED PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA WHO KNOW THEY CAN'T
BE EMPLOYED ANYWHERE ELSE EXCEPT
MAYBE A CARNIVAL DUNK TANK.
THEY NEVER GET FIRED.
THEY ONLY FAIL UP THE PRIME TIME
LINEUP UNTIL THEY GET JOBS
RUNNING CNN.
THESE ARE THE SAME CLOWNS WILL
ABIDE WHEN TRUMP CALLED
IMMIGRANTS AND ANIMALS WHEN IT
WAS MS-13.
THESE GROUPS WERE MORE OFFENDED
OVER CALLING KILLER THUGS
ANIMALS THAN THE ACTS BY THE
GANGS THEMSELVES.
THAT IS THE MEDIA'S M.O.
EVERYTHING IS A CRISIS EXCEPT
THE ACTUAL CRISIS.
WE'VE ALL HAD A FRIEND, WHEN THE
BOOZE RAN OUT AT A PARTY WOULD
DRINK FROM A BAND AND CUPS AND
POLISH OFF THE LISTERINE.
THAT'S THE MEDIA WITH THE
COLLUSION KEG RUN DRY, THEY ARE
NOW DESPERATELY LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING TO NUMB THE PAIN.
NOW WE ARE BACK TO TRUMP'S
PERSONALITY AGAIN.
HE'S MEAN, UNSTABLE.
WHEN HE DOESN'T LIKE A
SITUATION, HE CHANGES IT.
DID YOU HEAR?
HE FIRES PEOPLE.
I ONCE WORKED FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
THAT.
IN FACT, SHE FIRED ME.
THAT'S WHAT BOSSES DO IN THE
REAL WORLD.
THE REAL WORLD.
THE MEDIA SHOULD CHECK IT OUT
SOMETIME.
IT'S REALLY THE ONLY SHOW IN
TOWN AND I CAN'T STAND IT
BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T LAST A
MINUTE.
ALL RIGHT, FIRING IS NOT
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE.
I GUESS WE CAN'T FIRE PEOPLE
ANYMORE.
WE ARE SAFE.
>> I AM MAD AT YOU ABOUT THE
GOLDEN GIRLS SONG.
IT REMAINS ME OF WATCHING RERUNS
OF COLLEGE.
THIS IS THE CLASSIC LAZINESS OF
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA BECAUSE THEY
WOULD RATHER STAND IN FRONT OF
THEIR BATHROOM MIRROR AND
REHEARSE THEIR NEWEST SNEER.
AND A FACIAL EXPRESSION OF
DISGUST AT WHATEVER TRUMP WAS
DOING THAT DAY WERE PERFECT
THEIR GLOTTAL STOP.
IT'S JUST -- THE AUDIENCE CAN
KIND OF HEAR IT WHEN THE GUEST
IS TALKING BUT THEY ARE SHOWING
HOW APPALLED THEY ARE.
>> Juan: WHAT WAS THAT WORD?
>> Dagen: GLOTTAL STOP.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT THAT IS?
>> Dagen: THAT IS A GLOTTAL
STOP.
SORRY ABOUT THE SPITTLE.
>> Juan: ANY TIME YOU CAN
EDUCATE ME, I AM ALL FOR IT.
>> Greg: THE GOLDEN GIRLS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A FRIEND,
JUAN.
>> Juan: MY WIFE HAS A SIGN IN
THE KITCHEN THAT SAYS "SARCASM
SERVED DAILY.
CLOSE WHAT I THINK THAT'S YOU.
TRUMP FIRING PEOPLE FROM I.C.E.,
THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, THE SECRET SERVICE, I
THINK AT SOME POINT, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR ONE
DAY.
>> Greg: HE RAN
"THE APPRENTICE."
>> Juan: I THINK WE ARE DOING
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IN GENERAL, TRUMP IS LIKE A
LITTLE BOY WHO CRIES WELL.
OH, MY GOSH.
WE'VE GOT A CARAVAN COMING, AND
INVASION OF MS-13.
>> Greg: AND IT HAPPENED.
>> Juan: AND IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
WE SHUTDOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
EVERYBODY SAYS, WHAT CRISIS?
AND THEN WE HAVE A REAL
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS BUT OF
COURSE HE CRIED WOLF FIRST
REVIEW BELOW IT, THERE'S A REAL
CRISIS BUT HE'S CREATING A
CRISIS.
>> Greg: 103,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS.
>> Jesse: LISTEN TO WHAT JUAN
JUST SAID.
JUAN SAID THERE WAS NEVER ANY
CRISIS ANOTHER IS A CRISIS.
>> Juan: A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
CRISIS.
HE'S THE ONE WHO WERE SEPARATING
FAMILIES, CHILDREN FROM PARENTS.
HE'S THE ONE WHO SAID LET'S CUT
THE AID TO CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES OR WE CAN TRY TO DEAL
WITH IT.
HE TALKS ABOUT A WALL.
>> Greg: HE IS TRYING TO
CREATE A SOLUTION.
>> Juan: IF YOU WANT A
SOLUTION, LET'S LOOK AT THE
PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS IN TERMS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, YOU'RE MORE
ASIANS COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY.
I AM JUST SAYING LET'S LOOK AT
IT --
>> Jesse: DON'T GO THERE.
>> Juan: VISAS, LOOK AT THE
REAL ISSUES.
INSTEAD YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
WALL.
>> Greg: 103,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS.
JESSE.
>> Jesse: IT'S A 12 YEAR HIGH.
JUAN DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S AN
UNCOMFORTABLE CONVERSATION.
THE REST OF THE MEDIA DOESN'T
WANT TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
THE CONVERSATION IS HOW MANY
REFUGEES ARE WILLING TO ABSORB
IN THIS COUNTRY?
HOW MANY MIGRANTS IS THE
UNITED STATES ECONOMY WILLING TO
TAKE?
HOW MANY UNSKILLED WORKERS ARE
WE GOING TO TAKE INTO THIS
COUNTRY AND NOT TALK ABOUT IT.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
ALL OF THESE UNSKILLED WORKERS,
REFUGEES, MIGRANTS, THEY DON'T
GO TO GATED COMMUNITIES.
THEY DON'T GO TO NANCY PELOSI'S
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY GO TO BLUE-COLLAR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHAT DOES THAT DO FOR THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS?
WHAT DOES IT DO TO REAL ESTATE
PRICES?
WHAT DOES IT DO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS?
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THEIR
WAGES.
I AM ASKING THE QUESTION.
IF YOU ASK THIS QUESTION, THEY
CALL YOU A RACIST.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
WITH THE MEDIA DOES IS THEY
DISTORT THE REALITY.
THEY EITHER DON'T WANT TO COVER
THE CRISIS OR WHEN THEY COVERED,
THEY LIE ABOUT IT.
HERE'S A GREAT EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE GLORIA ON THE OTHER DAY.
HISPANIC FEMALE BORDER PATROL
AGENT WITH THE PRESIDENT TO SAID
STRATEGICALLY DEPLOYED WALLS
WORK TO REDUCE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND THEY REDUCE
ASSAULT ON BORDER PATROL.
NANCY PELOSI HAD JUST SOME WALLS
ARE IMMORAL AND WALLS DON'T
WORK.
WHY WOULDN'T THE MEDIA PLAYED A
GLORIOUS SOUND BITE, TAKE IT TO
NANCY PELOSI AND SAY NANCY, THE
EXPERT ON THE GROUND,
NONPARTISAN, SAYS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT YOU SAID.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION.
THEY DON'T DO THAT BECAUSE THE
MEDIA IS COLLUDING WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE TO ACT.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO HELP THEM
POLITICALLY AND HEARD THE
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT NOW THE CRISIS IS HURTING
THE COUNTRY AND THE MEDIA IS
HELPING THE DAMAGE BE DONE.
>> Greg: DANA, CARE TO WEIGH
IN?
>> Dana: KAI GO BACK TO THE
BEGINNING, WORKPLACE VIOLENCE.
ANYONE WHO SERVES IN A POLITICAL
POSITION IN ANY ADMINISTRATION
SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
IF THE PRESIDENT DECIDES IN THE
MORNING THAT TY IS NOT CUTTING
IT -- THAT TIE WOULD CUT IT.
I DON'T LIKE THE WAY YOU SAID
HELLO TO ME.
YOU ARE GONE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A REASON.
ALSO THE MEDIA WAS DISGUSTED BY
SECRETARY KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
THEY HATED HER.
THEY THOUGHT SHE HAD DONE A
TERRIBLE JOB, THAT SHE WAS LYING
FOR THE PRESIDENT, THAT SHE WAS
COMPLICIT IN ALL THESE THINGS,
SO NOW THEY WANT TO DEFEND HER
AND SAVES WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
QUESTION MIKE THAT'S SURPRISING.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT HAPPY WITH
THE POLICY SO HE IS CHANGING THE
PERSONNEL.
WILL HE GET A BETTER OUTCOME?
I DON'T KNOW.
EVERYTHING THEY COULD'VE DONE IS
THEY COULD'VE HAD GLORIA, THEY
SHOULD'VE PUSH THAT OUT, WHAT
THEY DO INSTEAD?
THEY PUSH KIRSTJEN NIELSEN OUT
RATHER THAN PUSHING THE GOOD
STUFF.
IT'S CHAOTIC.
PERHAPS THE NEW PEOPLE CAN GET A
HANDLE ON IT BUT INSTEAD OF
HAVING POLICYMAKING IN CONGRESS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS.
>> Greg: THE WAY YOU USE YOUR
HANDS, BIT THREATENING.
YOU ARE MOVING YOUR HANDS.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WOULD EVER SAY THEY WOULDN'T
PROTECT ME FROM YOU.
IF I USED WORKPLACE VIOLENCE, IT
WOULD BE JUSTIFIED.
JUAN GREG, DID YOU HEAR WHAT
DANA SAID?